the fact that their votes would not be
recognized as valid by the maduro
government
did not stop these venezuelans from
casting ballots in an opposition
organized referendum
aimed at showing the international
community that they want president
nicolas maduro out
we're plagued by government violence
there are armed groups everywhere
we need the world to intervene one way
or another to end this
despite reports of armed gangs loyal to
maduro attacking some of the estimated 3
000 makeshift polling stations
opposition leader juan guaydos
said millions had voted online or in
person
with this the illegitimate
unconstitutional and fraudulent
electoral process carried out last
sunday by maduro has been defeated
[Music]
here in chile the turnout was very low
the same in colombia home to the largest
venezuelan expat community
opposition leader leopoldo lopez who
escaped venezuela two months ago
was in bogota to send a message that
stronger international sanctions and
coordination are needed to obtain what
he says is the main goal
free and fair presidential elections
what else can the international
community
do short of an invasion to dislodge
nicolas maludo there is a lot more that
can be done
a lot more pressure diplomatic pressure
the use
of sanctions with a strategic focus
the political pressure the pressure uh
to isolate maduro as what it is a
criminal
and i can tell you something lucia that
we will continue
to go forward we will continue to do
whatever it takes in order to promote
freedom and free elections in venezuela
because we don't have another option and
the other option is to surrender and we
won't surrender
perhaps not but more and more
venezuelans are leaving the country
rather than fighting for change at home
and
after nearly two years of failed
attempts to force out maduro
rekindling faith in the current
opposition strategy may take
more than a symbolic referendum to see a
newman al jazeera
santiago